Hello friends and members of our SumTV
family. This is I'd like to know, our
Bible question and answer program. You
send in Bible- based questions. We give
you Biblebased answers. I am happy to
have you here and to be with you. My
name is CA Murray. To my right, Pastor
Steven Boore, our founder and president.
Pastor, always good to have you here.
>> Pleasure to be on this program.
>> And to my left, Pastor David Salazar,
our general manager of our Latina
network, doing a very, very fine job.
Hard worker for the Lord. David, always
good to share the desk with you.
>> Thank you, Pastor. It's always an honor
for me to be with you and Pastor Lord.
>> Again, if you have a Bible question, we
encourage you uh to send it in. Send it
to tvsumtv.
That's summ as in marytv.org. or rg and
we will get to your question just as
soon as we possibly can. We have a lot
of questions from around the world which
is a good thing for us but um maybe not
quite so good for you because you may
not hear the question the week after you
send it in. It may be a little while
down the road but we promise you we will
get to them. Now let me say this
quickly. If you get a question or send
in a question and you hear an answer
that doesn't quite line up with the
question as you send it in, it's
probably because there are several
people who had the same question. So, we
kind of combine the question and give a
blanket answer from the word of God for
all of them. Rather than answering the
same question several times, we combine
them. Answer one question one time and
it makes it a little more efficient for
us. But we encourage you to do so and we
love having your questions and of course
we love studying the word of God. Pastor
Boore, would you ask God's blessing upon
our sitting today and then we'll launch
out.
>> Let's pray. Father in heaven, we have so
many questions and many answers that we
will not have until we get to the
kingdom. But meanwhile, we have your
word and uh we can search for answers to
questions that are sent to us. We ask
that in this program you will give us
divine wisdom to answer these questions
accurately in harmony with your holy
word and with the spirit of prophecy. We
ask that those who are watching the
program will be blessed and that their
lives will be edified. We pray this in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question comes
to us from Australia. Gentlemen, they're
watching us on the other side of the
world and uh we're being a blessing.
This is from David in Australia.
Uh, the question is, is it wrong to be
touchy during church service? Boyfriends
and girlfriends and spouses stroking
each other and holding each other in the
pew while a church service is in
session. [snorts] It makes people around
them uncomfortable. It's awkward to
mention, but how should people be
conducting themselves while in the
church?
Bottom line
is that the purpose of the worship
service is to focus on God.
>> It's to worship God. And the principle
is that anything that distracts
>> from our worship to God, our focus on
God,
>> we should not do uh particularly not
only distract us but also distract other
people that are around us in the worship
service.
>> Amen. Uh there is a place for stroking
[laughter]
>> and praise the Lord.
>> The place for stroking is not in the
church. Not in the church
>> because uh because it distracts the
person who is doing the stroking. Uh I'm
just going to be bold and I'm going to
say it. And it also distracts as the
question says
>> the people that surround.
>> Yes. Uh so so the purpose of the worship
service is to study God's word, sing
praises to his name, pray to him uh and
uh and focus on service uh for him.
>> Uh anything that distracts from that uh
is not uh allowable in the church. other
things like for example uh texting,
chewing gum,
>> you know, giving crackers to the kids,
you know, that defeats the purpose of
the central focus of the worship
service, which is to worship the Lord.
>> Amen. There is this verse we have in 1
Corinthians
14:40
that speaks, "Let all things be done
decently and in order." And I think that
especially in the house of the Lord,
this house of God, as you well said,
pastor, is a place of worship. Worship
the creator. We're not there to uh try
to show affection per se for a private
for the private chamber. We are to be uh
mindful that keeping decency and order
in the house of God is important in our
behavior. How we interact, how we are uh
you can hold your hand with your spouse,
you can even put your hand around her.
But that is, you know, as long as it's
kept in a way where you're not
distracting and you are creating, you're
not creating this idea that you are in a
place where common things are done. You
need to make sure that you remember and
remind yourself that God wants us to be
before a holy God and we are to come
with humility with a heart to continue
and uplift our lives in holiness to the
Lord and not to uh become entangled with
ways to hold or or to touch one another
to kiss one another. I've seen these
things and are very distractful
distracting and are and quite honestly a
dishonor to the Lord. The house of God
is a house of worship.
>> Amen.
>> You took a little no bless there and I'm
going to do the [snorts] same thing. Um,
a couple of things come to my mind. When
I was my first Sabbath at the seminary,
Pioneer Memorial Church, uh, myself and
a couple other pastors and their wives,
we were attending the seminary and um,
they asked us to kneel to pray and so I
knelt to pray and I put my arms on the
pew in front of me. Now, I I I must
admit I did an infraction because for
some reason during that prayer, I opened
my eyes.
>> Um, and I was greeted with something I'd
never seen before or since. The fellow
in front of me was licking his I don't
know if his wife or girlfriend's face.
>> Um,
>> was he an Adventist?
>> He was in Pioneer Memorial Church.
[laughter]
He was. And I I just And so I I I I
spread my sin by elbowing the pastor
next to me. We're great friends. I was
in his wedding. He was in by I elbowed
him and he looked at me and I said, you
know, look at that.
>> And so he's like, so he elbows the third
pastor. There's three pastors together
next to him. So we're and this guy's
licking her face. This is during the
whole prayer. And I'm, you know, Christ
told the woman at the well, spirit in
truth,
what spirit is that? Where is that
coming from? That's that's that's not a
godly spirit. That's not a godly thing.
>> Why would you embarrass yourself and
your the person you love or care about
by doing something like that during
prayer in now the congregation can't see
you because their eyes should be closed.
Okay. Mine weren't, but God sees.
>> Yeah. You know, so what what's that
mindset? We talk about reverence. I've
I've pastored churches where the
reverendous sanctuary was painted on the
walls. I have always thought of
reverence as uh appropriate behavior,
>> not necessarily silence. I grew up in a
community, a church community where we
say a lot of amens, you know, and I'm
accustomed uh in fact my sermonic rhythm
is built on amens, you know, and my
rhythm is is is [clears throat] you have
this pause where you are expecting kind
of an amen and if I don't get them, it
kind of throws me. So I don't I don't
see that as a reverence. I remember
preaching in New Zealand
>> and [snorts] um oh my goodness, they
they they sat and they stared. They were
paying attention but nothing, you know.
So I'm thinking, well, maybe they're not
getting this, so I need to preach a
little bit more, a little bit harder, a
little bit more emphasis. And so at the
door, they're saying, "Pastor, we really
appreciate your message." D. And I asked
the elder, I said, "But nobody ever said
anything." And they said, "We wouldn't
say anything during a sermon. [snorts]
That's that's impolite. That's rude."
You know, for [laughter] a person that
grew up with this kind of servant volley
that [laughter] that was kind of
throwing me for a loop. They said, "No,
we would never ever ever say anything to
you." So what is class as reverence may
vary from culture to culture. But
handling your spouse is is is verboten
in all cultures. That that is not
something you want to do in the church.
>> Well, you know, the house of the Lord is
a house of prayer.
>> It is. We are to keep in mind that we're
coming to honor the Lord to to give
service and uh present ourselves in in
the desire to uplift us to his
>> to his holy you know experience. And so
we need to remember that we cannot mix
the holy with the unholy. Amen. and to
do practices that again in the privacy
of your home in your bedroom it's okay
to do but to extend those you know
displays of uh affection beyond that
especially to the church it's really a
disgrace to the Lord
>> yeah and disrespectful right I think we
have mined that question as as much as
given as much uh time as it as it needs
um the next question is anonymous it
comes from Sudan And pastor Boore, we
have looked at Isaiah 65:20 in the past.
Uh what say ye to this particular
question? Because this this person is uh
looking at this text as it affects and
impacts eternal life. Um and we we have
looked at this on this particular
program. Yes. Uh so what's your
response?
>> Well, the bottom line is that uh the
answer would be in the archives. So I
would recommend that uh that this person
who is anonymous uh would uh go to our
website and uh there's a collection of
all the programs that we've done and uh
there we have the answer. I remember
this question coming quite recently.
>> So if uh it's in the archives and uh the
person would not have to look all the
way back uh 10 years.
>> Yeah. because we did I remember because
South Sudan you know we don't get a lot
of questions from South Sudan in fact I
think that uh this is only the second
one and it might be the same one.
>> Uh so but basically uh let me just uh
refresh what the period this is talking
about. This is talking about after the
millennium
before the wicked are destroyed as they
are preparing to destroy in their minds
the holy city.
>> Holy city. That period is going to be
much longer than what we have generally
thought. In fact, the process of the
destruction of the wicked is going to
take a lot longer than what we've
thought. So Isaiah 65:20 fits within the
period, the long period between the
descent of the holy city, the gathering
of the wicked
>> and the final destruction of the wicked.
>> So that that'll give you the general
parameters. uh go to our archives and
you'll find a fuller answer.
>> All righty. Well said.
Thank you so much. Um
we have to pray for our brothers in
sisters in in Sudan and South Sudan. Uh
>> years and years of fighting and turmoil
and the Christian community is really as
it were taking it on the chin there. Uh
so we need to remember them in in in
prayer.
>> An anonymous question comes to us from
South Africa. Um David, I'm going to ask
you to turn with for me if you will to
Revelation 5:6 because we're going to
refer to that. The question is rather
lengthy and I suspect this will consume
the rest of our time for this particular
broadcast. I have a question uh in
relation to Revelation 5:6. Jesus Christ
is is described as having seven eyes
which are the seven spirits of God. We
know this to be the Holy Spirit who was
present in heaven before the day of
Pentecost. The number seven represents
the totality or fullness thereof. The
fact that the Holy Spirit is present
throughout the different uh throughout
the different church ages from 1 to
seven. Now, when the Bible says that the
eyes of Jesus are the Holy Spirit, my
question almost sounds silly, even as
I'm about to type it, but I am trying to
understand. Does that mean Jesus is not
seeing what is happening during the
church age? But the Holy Spirit is
because he is the one who is present on
earth. I know that God through the Holy
Spirit is present everywhere. But the
father and Jesus Christ are not present
everywhere. The Bible tells us that they
are in heaven. However, their
omniresence is through their
fornowledge.
This is not a question about the
godhead. However, uh as I was reading
the verse, what came to my mind is one
of the arguments of those who believe
that the holy spirit is not a person.
They say that the holy spirit is the
spirit of the father and the son.
basically a force of or energy combi
coming from both the father and the son
as I am thinking of this I had this
argument also in mind so he wants to
break us down uh does Jesus
does Jesus see what is happening here on
earth or does he see through the holy
spirit is he the only is he only relying
on his fornowledge and maybe can you
also address the last part about the
godhead
as you answer this particular question.
So, we've got a lot here. Um,
a lot. I've got a lot of texts. I
suspect you got a lot of text and I'm
looking at Pastor N's notes. You have a
lot of text also. So, who wants to weigh
out to weigh in on on this first? Um,
let's deal with the easy part. Is the
Holy Spirit a force or emanation from
God?
What do we how do we class the hol the
the Holy Spirit?
>> There's no doubt whatsoever that the
Holy Spirit is a person.
>> Okay.
>> Uh you know Ellen White has a statement
where she says that uh there are and
notice the num the emphasis on the
number three. There are three living
persons
>> in the heavenly trio
>> in the name of these three father, son,
and holy spirit. Now, uh, she couldn't
get any clearer. Four times, uh, in the
first sentence, she's using the word
three,
>> three living persons in the heavenly
trio in the name of these three, and
then she says, father, son, and holy
spirit. Uh, so there's no doubt
whatsoever that the holy spirit is a
person. However,
Ellen White makes it very clear that uh
the Holy Spirit uh the nature of the
Holy Spirit cannot be explained. In
fact, let me see if I can find this
statement here. Um and I'll read it
because it's uh really an important
statement. Um by the way that statement
um on three living persons is in Bible
training school March 1, 1906.
And this is what she says about the Holy
Spirit. It is not essential for us to be
able to define just what the Holy Spirit
is.
>> Christ tells us that the spirit is the
comforter, the spirit of truth which
proceeds from the father. It is plainly
declared regarding the Holy Spirit that
in his work of guiding men into all
truth, he shall not speak of himself.
>> And then she goes on and says, "The
nature of the Holy Spirit is a mystery.
>> Men cannot explain it because the Lord
has not revealed it to them. Men have
fanciful fanciful views. Men having
fanciful views may bring together
passages of scripture and put a human
construction on them. But the acceptance
of these views will not strengthen the
church. Regarding such mysteries which
are too deep for human understanding,
silence is golden. That's Acts of the
Apostles 51 and 52. So we can know
several things about the Holy Spirit. We
can know that he's a person. We we can
know that he convicts people of sin. We
can know u uh that he gives gifts. We
can see the gifts of the spirit. Mhm.
>> We can see the fruit of the spirit in
the life of people. Uh we know that the
holy spirit sanctifies human beings. So
we can know more about the functions of
the holy spirit than exactly the nature
of the holy spirit. Um Jesus compared
the holy spirit to wind. Um you know you
can certainly see the impact of the wind
but you can't see the wind. And so the
same is true of the holy spirit. We
can't understand the nature of the Holy
Spirit, but we can see the impact that
he produces in the lives of individuals
and in the life of the church.
>> I would add to that and and and well
said, pastor. Um
the Holy Spirit has intelligence. It can
be grieved.
>> Um it is a giver of life.
>> In John 3:8, it blows where it wants. So
it has it's volitional. It can determine
where it wants to go. So all of those
attributes that we would ascribe to
human beings to a living individual the
Holy Spirit possesses. It is always
referred to as he and not it.
>> Um so there are there are many many
things to let us know that it is a a a
functional intelligent entity. It is not
really important. We we tend to like to
put things under a microscope and and
dissect them. It's not really important
that we tear apart
who he is.
It's it's important for us uh to look at
and examine and to spend time on what he
is and what he does. Uh the fact that he
he does all of these things that you
mentioned are what's important to my
salvation. Maybe in heaven we'll
understand a little bit better uh the
intricacies of the Holy Spirit. But but
for right now that's not important. Uh
it's important that we accept him, that
we acknowledge him, that we give him the
kind of praise he is due because of his
works and what he does to the children
of men. David, you got something?
>> Yeah. In regards to the question, and I
think you have made it very clear the
nature of the Holy Spirit and and and
why it's so important to understand that
it is a person. But uh the question he's
asking, does Jesus see through the Holy
Spirit? Uh we know that he is
interceding for us. His role as the
intercessor in the heavenly sanctuary is
very clearly defined in the book of
Hebrews and and we understand that is
his role as he interceds for us before
the father. Now um the Bible and Christ
himself said in John 16
verse 7, nevertheless I tell you the
truth, it is to your advantage that I go
away. For if I do not go away, the
helper or the comforter, the Holy Spirit
will not come to you. But if I depart, I
will send him to you. So the Christ
didn't leave us and left us by
yourselves. He left the Holy Spirit. He
sent the Holy Spirit to be among us to
work in our hearts to be the presence of
God in this world. And therefore, how
exactly does the Lord sees everything or
knows everything is perhaps a little bit
um speculative if we want to you know do
there's not an actual declaration of the
Bible whether or not God is doing you
know uh this interceding Jesus
interceding and at the same time he sees
everybody at the same time even though
he's God so everything could be possible
for him. I think that trying to figure
out if the verse in Revelation is speaks
of the actual Holy Spirit being the eyes
of God.
I mean, it's not conclusive because
again the symbolism in Revelation
chapter uh three I believe was or five
rather by verse six where it mentions
Jesus having the lamb with the seven
eyes. It's a figurative are symbols of
his role of of knowing and understanding
and and seeing all things. But it's it's
probably trying to stretch beyond our
understanding how exactly the roles are
played and what exactly that God uh sees
or does not see. And I believe that it's
better to understand that just God told
us Holy Spirit is the one that's among
us dwelling and working for us as the
third person of the Godhead while Jesus
is interceding for us in the heavenly
sanctuary. But they're all connected and
working together for the good of
mankind. And Christ himself said that
not one bird falls to the ground without
the father taking notice of that. So if
God can sees all things and knows all
things, I believe Jesus can do the same.
And so there's no indication in this
verse that it limits the ability of
Jesus to be aware of everything as even
though he's working in the role of
intercession.
>> You know, we um I think that we need to
take into account the role of the angels
in all of this.
>> Yeah.
>> Um there's a statement in Ministry of
Healing 4:17.
It says the Bible shows us God in his
high and holy place.
>> God is not present physically
everywhere.
>> He's sitting on his throne in heaven.
>> Bible shows us God in his high and holy
place. Not in a state of inactivity, not
in silence and solitude, but surrounded
by 10,000 times 10,000 and thousands of
thousands of holy beings all waiting to
do his will
>> through these messengers. In other
angels, he is in active communication
with every part of his dominion.
>> By his spirit, he is everywhere present.
>> Yes.
>> And then uh she explains that the spirit
works through the angels. Says through
the agency of his spirit and his angels,
he ministers to the children of men.
>> Uh now there's another statement here um
that we find. Let me see if I can find
it here. This is in Desire of Ages 352
where she speaks about three persons.
Uh she uh God's people are to contend
with supernatural forces but they are
assured of supernatural help. All the
intelligences of heaven are in his army
and more than angels are in his ranks.
And then she speaks of the Holy Spirit.
Mhm.
>> I wish we had more time because there's
another part to that statement, but she
clearly identifies three there in Desire
of Ages 352 and how they relate to each
other.
>> This is a very, very good question.
Hopefully, we have given it the justice
and the answer that you were seeking.
Very complex, but well done and we thank
you for that. Again, our time has
slipped into eternity. Allow me in
closing to wish you both grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.
Heat.